now say than every other time today and
we talk telling us about some meddler
okay so I'm gonna be showing you about
bed alerting optimizers and learning
rules I'm going to be telling you why
it's hard and how you can really fix it
and just an applications before I start
I'm going to be talking about work done
by a lot of other people especially I
should call out Luke Mets who is the
first author on all the papers related
to this I should also maybe call up
Bryan Chung I think I saw the back of
the room somewhere and also Nero Jeremy
Daniel and and that's me at the end
[Laughter]
cool so overall outline in this talk I'm
going to give some into motivation for
what I should care about learned
optimizers I'm going to talk about some
of the challenges in training optimizers
someone solutions those challenges and
I'm gonna show to two specific examples
one where we Mediterranean optimizer
targeting a specific class of problems
and it outperforms all existing
techniques and a second where we met a
trained a update rule targeting a task
where we are unable to write down the
loss function directly that we wish to
optimize so maybe just to provide some
motivation one perspective on the deep
learning revolution is that it
correspond 'add to a transition from
using hand design features to using
learn features and as soon as the learn
feature started performing better than
hand design features then people started
using them everywhere and we were able
to build much more effective models or
you can think of meta learning as being
analogous to this but in the space of
loss functions or update rules or
architectures and in almost all cases we
are still using hand design loss
functions and and design optimizers and
design and they're often very poorly
matched to the task that we want to do
so even for instance in the case of
classification what we usually care
about is something like zero one loss on
a test set and what we typically trained
on is like cross-entropy loss on a
training set so we're like doubly
mismatched even the most basic machine
learning problem both in terms of data
set and in terms of loss function and
and so what we hope to do with meta
learning is transition from these lures
and loss functions and learned update
rules to loss functions and update rules
and architectures that are themselves
learn
so I think I've already said most of
this obviously update rules are
completely critical to the success of
deep learning most current methods are
hand design you can think of most
current optimizers especially are quite
simple functions that pull in a gradient
and output a parameter update and we are
going to instead learn those this is
however turns out to be quite
challenging for some reasons that I will
go more into depth so before we get into
metal learning let's consider just doing
gradient descent training of a neural
network with some parameters W which are
initialized randomly and to train for a
single iteration we take some loss
function and take its gradient with
respect to those parameters and subtract
it from the parameters times some some
learning rate we can do this over and
over and over again until we have fully
trained the model and then after we've
trained the model we evaluate
performance using some measure on that
final model for instance like train
accuracy or a validation validation loss
in meta learning we are going to replace
this gradient descent update with a
learned function U which has which
itself has some parameters theta and a
single meta training step is going to
correspond single meta training step is
going to correspond to updating these
parameters theta such that you do better
on your final performance measure of
your optimization run and you can do
this over and over and over again and we
call this outer training loop for this
optimization of theta
either outer training
or meta training refer to theta as the
outer parameters and we refer to this
like standard optimization problem where
one standard optimization problem is a
single provides a single update step for
the outer training problem as the inner
inner problem so will you always be the
gradient and the current parameters and
so there's a there's a catch-all dot dot
dot there and in fact in practice we're
going to also feed use some set of
additional statistics based upon their
history gradients baby there's anything
you like and we also discriminate with
having some extra state variables that
new inputs and outputs and houses the ES
and the short answer is that the more
internal state you give you the less
stable training becomes because you're
now building a more and more complex
dynamical system inside every step of
your complex dynamical system maybe
expand I should also emphasize I
strongly encourage you to interrupt me
talk back to me so cool so this is is a
set up
however outer optimization turns out to
be extremely hard number one it's very
expensive in that every single outer
training step is an entire inner
training problem second the outer loss
evaluations are often quite noisy they
depend on exactly how you initialize
your inner problem and can have very
high variance over inner initialization
and finally the outer loss surface is
typically complex or or chaotic and as a
result all the papers what do you mean
by complexity out of here
I actually I'm gonna go into that so as
a result of these problems all the
current approaches to learned optimizers
require some extremely fragile tricks to
get them the Train at all and they
don't for the most part generalize to
new problems or even necessarily for the
same problem very well of course I mean
it seems difficult to even imagine
Trenton back prop through one step of
the outer yeah all the updates you ever
made and trying to change them and see
the history is there's you know so you
must have some smarter way trying to do
it for proposal so I mean the short
answer is just automatic differentiation
it's just enough yeah so so it is kind
of brutal and so there's maybe two
classes of approaches that people might
use to solve this type of problem one of
them is blackbox optimization which
involves techniques like random search
or reinforcement learning or evolution
and if you want to think about
estimation of the hyper parameters of a
standard optimizer as a meta learning
problem then random search would be the
most common technique that people
currently use two to five
parameters of their optimizer however
all of these techniques scale quite
badly to high dimensional state spaces
and thus do not work very well at
training flexible parametric optimizers
the other class of techniques are those
that use gradients gradients give you
much richer training signals and this is
technically allowed in that the entire
training process is differentiable the
final parameters of your model are just
what you got by composing your
parametric update rule you with itself
many many times and so similar to
training in R and n you can back pop
through that process and directly
compute radius with respect to beta
typically when people yes question have
you also fed random bits and random bits
into into you does you also just get
some pure randomness
no but you gets more than the friend in
this in terms of the
okay I'll see if they get later offline
so typically when people are training a
dynamical system such as an RNN or such
as unrolled optimization they make their
lives easier by performing truncated
back propagation through time and
interpolated back propagation through
time what you do is you take your inner
optimization process and you run it for
some number of steps and then rather
than going all the way to the end before
computing it other loss you compute your
outer loss after some fixed number of
steps in this case - and then you back
prop through those two steps and then
you initialize where you ended up at the
last time and you run optimization for
another two steps and you back propagate
through those two steps and you do this
over and over and over again and this is
great in that you have many more
gradients for each run of the inner
optimization it's also great in that it
turns out and I'll show in a moment your
loss surface is better behaved but it is
unfortunate in that doing this you are
of course computing your outer loss in a
biased way you're interested in the loss
you get by running optimization for all
steps and then completing a loss and
because you only back propagate a few
stop steps and then cut the gradients
you are just dropping terms from the
irradiance in rnns
those are not necessarily harmful in
optimization the best-performing hyper
parameters are often in RN ends this is
I'm sorry
in optimizer is this is often far more
harmful so there are perhaps two
conflicting goals one is we'd love to
just do one long unrolled optimization
which will give us a much less biased
Optima
estimate but is unfortunate in that each
iteration then of the outer training
loop is quite slow and is also
unfortunate and that the lost circles
for not be more horrible the other
approach is that you do many many short
unroll steps in which case it's fast to
train and the loss surface is smooth but
you end up with very biased radiance and
so diving in a little bit more to those
those challenges which I've liked
heavily alluded to let's first start by
looking at the problem bias induced by
short unrolls
in that learning
I was going to ask whether there's a
role for things like hyper networks here
so hyper networks I think could provide
a that would be a great research project
like you could for instance design a
hyper network so that optimization in
the latent spaces network optimization
there's a new inoculation here very much
discipline propagating values in the
forward pass but only truncating the
backward yeah you could completely just
put the sequences into this thing and do
both forward and backward in essentially
the stage won't be one so so so actually
in some ways that's better and that you
have an unbiased gradient but it's worse
in that you only ever run optimization
if you're like truncate three steps you
only ever run optimization for three
steps so you only get to see problems
that you can get you by running like
three training steps
cool so here we're looking at a at a
nice toy system and what we're doing is
we are training a two layer MLP on em
nest
using Adam and we're running training
for four ten thousand steps and then we
are trying to optimize the learning rate
that we use an adam being order to train
on this problem as quickly as possible
and just to be a grid search this dashed
line here corresponds to the optimal
learning rate and so what you find is
that when you back propagate through all
ten thousand training steps then of
course you're descending the right law
surface and you you ready to send in
terms of log learning rate and you get
to the right log learning rate as you
reduce the number of the length of the
enrolls that you back pop through then
you converge to suboptimal learning
rates and in fact even doing a hundred
unrolls
you actually move in the wrong direction
after initializing your learning rate
and we'll end up with a learning rate
for adam that's worse than the one that
you started with
so bias has yes house incitive is that
just to an arbitrary initial learning
rate because if you move in right
direction
yes if you if you'd the final learning
rates that you converge to are a
function of the enrolling that's not the
initial learning rate they started with
so so you can find yourself at
significantly suboptimal learning rates
even if you do a surprisingly large
number of enrolls so here for instance
we're like doing that propagating
through a hundred steps of optimization
which which may usually you might think
is enough to get a good sense of the
gradient and actually even for doing
something as simple as estimating the
optimal learning rate you end up with an
optimal learning rate which is quite far
from from what you would want to be
remembered number of steps in the
optimization problem has to be fixed a
plate cannot be decided adaptively
yeah yeah that you would have to there
are perhaps ways to differentiate
through a decision like that but it
would add a great deal of additional
complexity cool maybe maybe the more
exciting and also more pathological
problem that you run into is that you
find that the gradients with respect to
the optimizer parameters theta often
diverge or alternatively that your outer
law surface is chaotic and maybe this is
best illustrated to start with in a
thule 1d system so here we have a
one-dimensional law surface and we're
trying to do gradient descent on this
law surface and we're doing this with
SUV plus momentum and if you have a
small value of the momentum parameter
then you will descend into this first
well if you have a large value of this
momentum parameter then you will make it
over this hump and you will descend into
this second well and so here I'm
plotting as a function of a problem
training step what your inner parameter
value is and here I'm plotting log of 1
minus omentum and for a small value the
mentum you end up right here in this
first well for a large value of the
momentum you end up here in the second
well and as you increase the momentum
even more you begin to oscillate between
the two wells before finally settling
into one or the other so each of these
y-coordinates corresponds to a different
lost value here so for instance this
this y-coordinate equals 0 corresponds
to a loss of 5 y-coordinate equals
whatever that value is about 3
corresponds to a loss is 0 and right
between the two you have a ridge with a
loss of 11
so we can do is we can plot the loss
that you end up with after a given
number of training steps as a function
of the momentum of the parameter of your
optimizer and so what you see is if you
only train for a small number of steps
like 10 steps then this function is
relatively smooth but we are iterating a
dynamical system over and over and over
and over again and the Namgyal systems
like this are prone both to collapse the
fixed points and to have like
discontinuous transitions between
various points they collapse too and as
you increase the number of training
steps then you find that your lost
surface in terms of this one - momentum
parameter starts to develop
discontinuities and so you might imagine
the problem of meta training and
optimizer where you unroll the optimizer
100 training steps as the problem of
doing gradient descent on this purple
surface and as you can see this purple
service both has like rapid extremely
high frequency fluctuations in its loss
value and additionally gradients will
not be very useful because they're going
to be very they're very close to zero or
very close to infinity
so what about neural networks all the
examples have shown so far our Fotolia
toy systems does something similar
happen when you attempt to meta train a
we need time to train a neural network
or Mediterranean optimizer for neural
network so here we have a
two-dimensional slice through the weight
space of a three layer MLP that we're
training an amnesty using out and here
you can see we have a very narrow range
of that should say log learning rate we
have a very narrow range of log learning
rates and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna look at the trajectory that you
trace out in the parameter space of this
three layer MLP as a function of the log
learning rate over this very narrow
range and initially you perform a few
iterations and all the all the learning
rates chased out nearly identical
trajectories and then after around ten
iterations of training they begin to
split and 20 30 40 50 60 70 80 90 and
what you see is that these tiny changes
in initial learning rate lead to
dramatic bifurcations in the path you
take when optimizing a three-layer
neural network and additionally every
single one of these final locations is
going to have a slightly different loss
value so if you were to look at the loss
value as you adjust this learning rate
you would find that it is extremely
rough and nearly discontinuous and in
fact this is maybe my favorite
visualization
so so far everything we looked at has
been has been training a lot guys want
to make sure it still yeah yeah we're
still we're still in training lost land
so perhaps my favorite visualization of
this talk what we can do is we can try
to see this more visually so here we
actually have a three layer MLP that
we're training and we're gonna train
this three layer MLP with a parametric
optimizer and what we're showing here is
a two-dimensional slice through the
parameter space of this learned
optimizer and we're gonna I'm going to
tell you about the architectures learned
optimizer in a minute and what we see is
that if you only do one enroll then the
Lost landscape the outer Lost landscape
is quite smooth and it would probably be
quite quite straightforward to do
gradient descent on this on this
landscape you want to go from the larger
or wider values to the darker of lacquer
values the lower darker values as we
increase the number of unroll steps we
do before we're evaluating the outer
loss you begin to see more and more
complex structure entering into the lost
landscape until by the time you've done
fifty unroll step fifty enrolls
basically every single pixel has a
different loss value and doing
optimization on this lost surface is of
course quite challenging either either
via gradient descent or even be a random
search methods because the lost value in
many regions of parameter space changes
so rapidly and so just
yeah it seems in these examples the
local structure of the law surface is
bad yeah isn't so terrible that is a
beautiful observation which which
perhaps directly moves into the neck
there's about 2,000 outer parameters so
2,000 parameters in the optimizer and I
would have to think for the neural
network but it's probably like full so
hopefully I've now convinced you that
there are like two classes of
pathologies if you try to Mediterranean
optimizer one of those classes of
pathologies is that it's very easy to
get biased gradients and those bias
gradients can take you to qualitatively
poor solutions the other class of
pathologies is that you're a lost
landscape which comes from iterating
this light dynamical system can be
chaotic and can have a lot of extremely
high frequency structure and your
discontinuities so now that I've
introduced those problems I'm going to
propose one one class of solutions to
this problems specifically I'm gonna say
that we can do fix this to a remarkable
degree using variational optimization so
what you can do is if L of theta is your
original outer lost surface you can
define some distribution over
perturbations to your parameters and you
can convolve L of theta with that
distribution so for instance here what
we're doing is we're taking the
parameters theta and we're perturbing
them in a Gaussian distribution around
theta and then we're averaging the
original loss over that distribution
perturbations and so what this does is
it effectively smoothes your lost
landscape and suppresses the
high-frequency structure and as Boris as
Boris noted often we find that the
global or at least larger scale
structure these lost landscapes remains
relatively relatively well-behaved
even as the local structure becomes like
pathologically poor so once we does this
make sense several cool
so once we've written down this
variational loss we can write down two
different unbiased gradient estimators
for words loss one of those gradient
estimators uses the score function trick
or the like reinforced style style
estimator where we write this in terms
of the gradient of the log normal
distribution this is the same strategy
used in evolutionary strategies the
other unbiased estimator we can write
for this gradient is by using the
parameterization trick where we write
theta tilde as theta plus a frozen off
set drawn from a normal distribution and
back propagate the entire system and so
both of these will mean expectation
estimate the same gradient of this
smooth loss function
but they will have extraordinarily
different variants properties so
especially if the lost surface is smooth
and well-behaved then the Reaper
amortization style gradient will have
much much much lower variance and I
think this is what people's intuition
generally is is that the memorization
tricks oil gradients are much better
estimators on the other hand if the lost
surface has high curvature or a lot of
stochasticity then the es style grading
estimator is going to be far better and
maybe just as a simple toy illustration
of this if you have a lost surface that
goes like this then the es style
estimator is effectively taking a finite
difference of widely separated points
and it's going to give you a low
variance gradient estimator while the
parametrization trick is sampling a
bunch of points computing the gradient
each of those points and then averaging
the gradient and so if the gradients
have a lot of high frequency noise it's
going to give you a very high frequency
estimator and in fact for training a
learned optimizer whose architecture I'm
going to show you in a moment we can
plot the gradient variance of each of
these gradient estimators over the
course of training
are there is also these are these
results do you mean the different
variants properties or I'm almost
completely positive there are we have we
don't talk we don't do theoretical right
yeah yeah yeah no it's pretty it's
pretty I think it's pretty
straightforward actually this person any
question but some extent on like with
evolution strategies are sort of setting
like a radius in which air yeah
influence yeah yeah and actually
actually for both of these we're
choosing this radius right these both
have like noise drawn from the same yeah
this is the hyper perm for the system
and you need to say something I guess
it's a hyper hyper parameter which we
did relatively little hyper hyper
searching over but but if you were to do
this properly you would you would do
that switch over that I guess like sort
of reason why I ask is that in terms of
those findings about like their variance
I mean I'm just gonna based on like this
sort of visual intuition can apply you
get high okay so qualitatively what'll
happen explaining the difference in the
result it's like if you just switch the
radius the radii of the different
approaches that yeah okay so Paul it's
qualitatively other imagine what happen
is the Reaper amortization gradient is
going to have a variance which is
roughly constant even as you change your
your perturbations because the repairs
ation gradient its variance just comes
from the variance in the analytic break
in the function whereas I would expect
whereas the evolutionary strategies
gradient has variance from two different
sources one of those sources is like
shot noise or like sampling noise and
that's gonna be constant and then the
other source is the like spatial scale
over which you're averaging in that so
like one of those - noise terms for yes
is gonna drop as you increase that
radius so as you make it larger I would
expect that
this term remains roughly the same
variance and this term like drops down
to like some asymptotic constant thanks
but we did in fact measure this
empirically and what you find is that at
least for this particular task early and
meta training where you're still in a
smooth region of the outer Lost
landscape that the Reaper amortization
style gradients is roughly five orders
of magnitude better than the es
gradients so in terms of variance so
it's greatly beneficial to use the
gradients when you are in a smooth
region in the Lost landscape on the
other hand later in outer training you
find that the Reaper amortization
gradient ends up being up July 20 or 25
orders magnitude worse in variants than
the es gradient and so you might imagine
why like previous work that tries to
train their learned optimizer using this
has to jump through a lot of Hoops in
order to get learning to perform in a
stable fashion and just maybe like a
qualitative observation in terms of
optimization the best performing
optimization hyper parameters are almost
always on the edge of the stable regime
so even if you just like training a
quadratic your best learning rate for
like a milk interesting quadratic is the
largest learning rate before you diverge
along the highest curvature direction
and so this is kind of the source for
why you get this extreme instability
especially later in training it's
because you learned optimizer the best
parameters are learned optimizer are
right on the edge of the parameters have
learned optimizer where everything blows
up an argument for decreasing the radius
of like when you're doing the
refrigerator Liebherr commentary
stationary like during the course oh you
mean like annealing the radius yeah
alright because the blue line is the
limit as that radius leader
the no no no the blue line
the the blue so this entire plot is for
a fixed radius so it's a fixed at the
end are you factoring out the valence
that's being added to the green it's
because of aliens across many patents as
a night so let's say you're measuring
the this is this is the full fulfill
variance so there's there's many batches
of barians in here as well it's just a
mini of that batch variance is like
swamped by your by your your the
variance of your gradient estimator I've
said I'm not sure if that's true for the
yes case it I I'm actually not sure what
the relative contribution is but this
includes many vegetarians
in that pot is there any rule for
starting with RP before you get later on
yeah I mean this this definitely
suggests that you might want to one
strategy might be to start with one and
then when it goes on the table switch to
the other we actually did something
which is maybe slightly more principled
but also slightly more expensive which
is we just always computer both and you
can reuse the same the same points for
both estimators so you can evaluate the
functions at the same points you
evaluate the gradients and my estimators
and especially what you can do is you
can use inverse variance waiting to come
up with optimal variance combination at
least if you imagine that the variance
is like independent between the two
estimators just take a weighted sum of
the two unbiased grading estimators
maybe a nice property of doing this is
that the worst case variance of gee
merged is the minimum of the variance of
either of the two estimators okay so
great so just talked about a method to
deal with the Caddick loss surface we do
something much simpler to deal with the
bias current rotations which is
unrolling entire sequence is still quite
expensive so we just anneal this we
start out by unrolling many short
segments and then over the course of
meta training we increase the length of
the unrolls
until the very end a meta training we
are unrolling over the full 10,000
training steps
and we are going to demonstrate the
utility of this by using it to train
some optimizers especially an optimizer
targeted at a specific set of tasks I'm
not going to go super into the details
of the architecture that we use the
optimizer I'm just going to tell you
that it is a per weight MLP so you have
a little copy of this exact same MLP
with the exact same parameters for every
weight in your network this MLP is going
to take as input a number of features
that we know are useful for existing
optimizers like the gradient and the
gradient average over various time
scales
and it's going to produce as output and
update to the parameters in fact
decomposed as a log burning rate and a
copy attraction
we are going to apply this optimizer to
the task of training on imagenet and i'm
gonna go a little bit in depth into how
we divide up train and test because
people always get a little bit confused
about this for for meta training so
we're going to do here is we are going
to divide all the imagenet classes into
an outer train set of classes and then
an outer test set of classes that are
never seen during outer training and
then within each one of these classes
our data is divided up into an inner
train set and then an inner validation
and an inner test set
we're gonna target 10-way classification
problems and we're going to target
training a three layer convolutional
neural network and we're choosing a very
specific task and a very specific set of
data sets such that we don't have to
worry about like defining the
distribution of a passive the optimizer
supposed to work well on maybe one
really cool aspect about this is
traditionally optimizers target the
training loss in reality what we care
about is not training a loss we care
about generalization loss and so we
could imagine using two different losses
for our meta training one of those is
the training loss and the other is the
validation loss on the inner problem
this is kind of cool because it means
that by meta training you can directly
target generalization you can directly
target an optimizer which is going to do
well on a validation set
I don't think you go through the skin so
the entire problem we're solving is we
want to find the weights of some
parametric optimizer and we're going to
do this with like variational
optimization and tricky to backpal we're
going to take an expectation over tasks
that we want the optimizer to solve and
then we are going to for each of those
tasks evaluate our outer objective which
of these are going to be training loss
at the end of training or validation
loss at the end of training and then for
each of those outer objectives we are
going to apply the learned optimizer to
training a small three layer content on
a subset of image classes
the results are as shown here first of
all we can look at the case where we met
a train targeting train loss and in that
case we find that the learned optimizer
is able to optimize training loss far
faster than any other of the optimizers
I would by the way specifically like to
call out our controls here so the purple
and green controls are Adam with l2
regular is a regular ization l1
regularization and learning rate decay
where the number of hyper parameters we
have a date we have all the Adam hyper
parameters we have the two learning
rates of pay coefficients and we have
the two reservation coefficients and we
try and we evaluated over a thousand
training instances for each of this to
the Z these are very well hyper
parameter optimized Adam and so what you
find is that when you target a training
loss we do much better than existing
optimizers even when they're well
hopping a program for optimized but
interestingly when we then evaluate the
same optimizer and the test loss it
diverges so in fact fitting as rapidly
as possible to the training loss is like
horribly bad on the test loss on the
other hand if we train a learned
optimizer targeting the validation loss
rather than the training loss then we
find that on training loss it does worse
than any of the other optimizers it's
the orange line but on test loss it does
better than any of the other optimizers
so yes this is a classification task and
this is like hold out hold out classes
verjus but you still
pacification because if your norm goes
to infinity yeah we did that we did not
measure that or if we did I don't know
what the answer is but that is that is
possible
I'd also by the way like to emphasize
that this is wall clock time and not and
not iterations um so so this is also
despite the additional overhead that
we're paying with the where and learned
optimizer and three minutes all right
I'm gonna skip this we looked at how
well it generalize to new tasks the
answer is a sort of does I want to
really quickly introduce one other
project I think is super neat which is
you can also use meta learning to
optimize a task where you're unable to
write down the loss a training time
maybe the canonical example of this is
unsupervised representation learning
where your goal is to expose some
high-level attributes of the data like
object identity without label you want
to get all of image net and come up with
like like object ID without knowing the
labels and this is really challenging
because we need to write down a learning
rule or a loss function that optimizes
for something that we don't know a
training time on current approaches to
this involved just like hand designing a
surrogate loss like log likelihood or a
VA EE or again or something and hoping
that a useful representation arises as a
side effect and I can show you some
plots later if you're curious
illustrating that there's like a massive
objective function mismatch in that case
however there are many tasks for which
we do know what the eventual desired
high level attributes that we want are
so for instance we know that if we do
unsupervised training an image net we
really want the model to learn a high
level representation which captures like
object class and so the proposed
approach is that we're gonna meddler an
unsupervised update rule that trains
models to have a representation which is
a really good representation for
supervised tasks where we know what the
answer that we wanted to get is and then
we're going to apply that metal learned
unsupervised update rule
two totally new tasks and I'm gonna skip
the details we couldn't get have like 90
seconds and I am just going to say first
of all it works and maybe a little bit
interesting is that we can Mediterranean
on a distribution of tasks distribution
of datasets and we can generalize to new
data sets and we outperform like a
vanilla ve which is nice
most exciting for me is our hope here is
that we can med-alert an unsupervised
learning rule which generalizes to any
data set or any data modality or any
task and so we met a trained on a whole
bunch of image tasks and we can measure
transfer to a totally different task in
this case to sentiment classification
and IMDB movie reviews and we find that
over the course of meta training we
actually learn a learning rule that is
significantly better on this text task
just like totally different domain tasks
although later in meta training the
learning rule begins to overfit to them
to the images domain and does does worse
on the text yes I think I'm like so over
time so I'm just gonna go to the last
slide and then maybe there'll be time
for questions so summary of the entire
talk both bias and chaos cause problems
and meta training we have a proposal for
how to fix this by using a variational
loss we demonstrate that it works by
training a task specific learned
optimizer i additionally think that meta
learning is particularly nice in that it
allows you to target tasks where you
can't write down the objective that you
care about but you can write down and
meta objective you care about where
unsupervised representation learning is
one example of this
and in addition we show that we can
train a
learn update rule I'm gonna taste
learning okay a little overtime let's
just take one question while Karolina
sets up so y'all applying about sponsor
survivors but since only question a
little bit more like this so it seems
like a little bit out of the view why
that's going from like neural network
training is already expensive and you
sort of go from something like
end-to-end squared
yeah like I granted I know it's earlier
than the basic research things but this
curious like has there yet been a payoff
to justify it like is there a single
task where the upshot has been an
apology or instead of this imply missed
it we're like meta-learning truly
outperforms anything else that we have
to justify like the massive computation
so there has definitely been a payoff in
terms of architecture design so though I
didn't discuss that in this news talk
there has been a lot of work on like
neural architecture search architecture
design and there it has definitely paid
off I think in terms of optimizers were
right on the edge so I think here we
demonstrated like if what you care about
is training a three-layer confident on
on an image data set then I think hand
you an optimizer right now that will
outperform on in wall clock time any
existing optimizer but that hasn't been
generalized to a larger set of tasks yet
and no one has scaled it up to like a
production scale I guess
okay let's thank the speaker again